Drei Punkte liegen zwischen Tabellenplatz 2 und Tabellenplatz 11 in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Jedes Wochenende ist fröhliches Tabellenspringen angesagt und mittendrin dabei die SV Elversberg. Der SSV Jahn Regensburg hat damit als Tabellenletzter jetzt nicht so ganz viel mit zu tun, aber über diese beiden Vereine und die Lage der Liga spreche ich jetzt mit SVE-Fan Jonas Nickolai und Jahn-Blogger Thomas Süß. Viel Spaß.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gebühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, wir sind zurück mit einer neuen Ausgabe der Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ich bin Eva Lothar Bohle. Meine Stimme ist heute nur so zu 75 Prozent anwesend. Bitte, das zu entschuldigen. Es ist Winter. Mein Fußballverein macht mal ausnahmsweise nicht ganz so viel falsch. Von daher ist meine Stimme etwas strapaziert. Aber ich freue mich sehr, euch pünktlich zur Adventszeit mit besinnlichen und weniger besinnlichen Themen zu unterhalten. Aber das mache ich natürlich wie immer nicht alleine, sondern habe mir zwei wunderbare Gäste dafür eingeladen. Zum einen ist Jonas Nickolai mal wieder dabei, den ihr sicherlich noch von der letzten Elversberg-Folge kennt. Hallo, Jonas, schön, dass du dabei bist.
Hallo, danke, dass ich wieder da sein darf. Und freue mich auch, dass ich wieder da sein darf, dass wir es geschafft haben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir haben letztes Mal drüber spekuliert. Und dann darf ich Thomas Süß vom der Jahn-Blog begrüßen. Ich glaube, du bist auch das erste Mal im Rasenfunk dabei, hast dir aber das Intro fachgerecht mitgetrommelt, für alle unmitgesprochen, für alle, die hier nur mit Audio dabei sind. Hallo, Thomas.
Servus, ja, ich höre ganz gern tatsächlich die Ausgaben zur Frauen-Bundesliga. Verfolgt das immer so ein bisschen mehr? Und ich bin immer noch ein bisschen verwirrt von diesem ganzen Jubel, da am Anfang Tor und sowas. Diese Jubel, die kenne ich gar nicht mehr. Das ist bei mir auch ein Viel zu selten. Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Kann man das immer erklären?
Ja, wir liegen dir direkt mit dem Finger in eine Wunder-Ausschau mit dem Intro. Dafür sind wir bekannt. Aber bevor wir starten, wie immer natürlich auch der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk, er ist und bleibt. Werbe, Paywall und Sponsoren frei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden als Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr könnt Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen werden. Und stellvertretend geht der Dank dafür raus in dieser Folge an Marco B., Caterwa Colonia, Jan, ein Fan aus Österreich, der da hinten und Samuel L. Vielen Dank, dass ihr Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen seid und ihr ermöglicht unter anderem, dass unsere Gäste einen Honorar kriegen, aber eben auch, dass Marco und ich ja ab und zu mal über die zweite Liga quatschen dürfen. Das freut uns sehr. So, aber jetzt lass uns tatsächlich mal reinstarten und da wir gewohnt als erstes auf die Lage der Liga schauen. Es ist ja schon wieder einiges passiert. Diese zwei Wochen, das ist einfach fast, also kannst du ein ganzes Buch mitfüllen. Unter anderem wurde ja Steffen Baumgart nach dem 2-2 gegen Schalke beim HSV entlassen. Und dieser HSV konnte am Wochenende unter Interimstrainer und vielleicht neuem Cheftrainer Merlin Polzin das erste Mal seit dem 20. Oktober wieder ein Pflichtspiel gewinnen. Aber lass uns doch mal generell auf die Liga gucken. Jonas, was fällt dir denn da so besonders auf momentan?
Also ich finde es einfach krass. Ich habe beim letzten Mal, als ich hier sein durfte, habe ich gesagt, ich freue mich, dass wir im Nirgendwo der Tabelle sind. Das gibt es im Moment so gar nicht. Also entweder spielt der Verein oben mit oder hat zumindest die Chance, oben anzugreifen von der Punktzahl her. Oder dann ab 12 fangen die Vereinen dann an, die unten mitspielen. Also es gibt keinen Verein, der jetzt irgendwie so, wo man sagt, da wird man jetzt mal schauen, ob der noch irgendwo reinrutscht oder so. Die hängen schon alle irgendwo mit drin. Also das finde ich schon irgendwie krass, dass sich das auch kaum oder wenig ändert. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert.
Das ist alles irgendwie so zwischen Genie und Wahnsinn, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich habe mir die Tabelle gerade aufgemacht. Nebenbei bin ich mir dankgehaust, falls man mal gut zu wissen, dass wir erfolgreicher sind, wie ihr hier. Wir hatten vom 2. Elfen das letzte Mal gewonnen gegen so einen Verein, irgendwie Elversberg heißt. Weiß nicht, ob ihr den kennt. Auf jeden Fall, wenn ich mir die Tabelle auch so anschaue, aber wie gesagt so Genie und Wahnsinn, da ist jetzt eine leidvolle Erinnerung. Momentan Nürnberg auf 12. Die haben vor ein paar Wochen nach 3-8 gegen uns gewonnen. Gut, dass es nicht schwer ist, gegen uns mit vielen Toren zu gewinnen. Das ist bekannt. Aber mit 3-8 meint man eigentlich nicht, dass die auf 12 sind. Oder auch Kräuter, die 4-0 gegen uns am Anfang der Saison gefunden haben, wo du dir gedacht hast, wow, krass, also die ziehen mal wieder durch. Die sind bestimmt oben mit dabei. Sie sind auf Platz 13 und der Berand hier am Mittendrin, der Baum. Alex Zorniger weg. Ich kann den Nachnamen vom Sportmanager nicht aussprechen. Azuzi. Danke. Da denkt man sich, hä, was machen die da unten? Hingegen ist dann auf einmal Kaiserslautern, die, wo sonst immer irgendwo rumgetröppelt sind, jetzt auf einmal Dritte. Also das ist irgendwie komisch.
Ja, ich fand es zum Beispiel echt krass, wenn man das HSV-Kaiserspiel verfolgt hat. Also ein Tor hat immer diese komplette Tabellendynamik durcheinander gebracht und das war ja, also es war wirklich irre, das mit zu beobachten. Und das ist dann natürlich auch so schwierig. Gucken wir beispielsweise auf Fortuna Düsseldorf, guckt man auf die Tabelle, sagt man, oh wow, die sind aber ganz schön abgestürzt. Naja, aber abgestürzt in dieser Liga unter diesen Top 10 ist halt absolut relativ. Du bist halt nur, also Torverhältnis, das goldene Wort, egal ob Champions League, ein neues Format oder halt 2. Liga. Also das, Thomas schlägt schon mal die Hände vor den Kopf zusammen. Das wird nicht richtig.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Wir kommen noch an den Punkt, die 2. Liga als neue Champions League zu betiteln.
Okay. Nein, nein, ich meine nur, es ist, egal.
Das meine ich nicht. Ich meinte, ich kenne kein Torverhältnis. Also, ich bin nur, da müssen wir nicht näher drauf eingehen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich muss es nachher trotzdem schon mal erwähnen. Also vielleicht hältst du dir an dem Part schon mal die Ohren zu. Aber es ist ja schon, es ist ja echt absurd. Also irgendwie, wenn man es dann wirklich mal mit der Bundesliga vergleicht, wo, ja, keine Ahnung, da gibt es immer so zwei, drei spannende Partien, die auch wirklich in der Tabelle viel bewegen. So, aber sonst hat man ja eigentlich nicht so dieses. Also man hat ja in der 2. Liga wirklich jede Partie bedeutet. Große Auswirkungen, mehr oder weniger, für die Tabelle. Und das mag ich auch, weil ich habe ja so viele Aktien dann doch nicht drin in dieser Liga, anders als ihr beide. Und ich mag es einfach, da von außen draus zu gucken, weil das gleichzeitig eben auch heißt, dass in diesen Spielen alles passieren kann. Also da, gerade wenn wir gleich über die SVE reden, so alleine, was die für Ergebnisse im November hatten, es ist einfach, das musst du auch erstmal anderen Leuten erklären. Ich glaube, das ist schon einfach von außen ein absoluter Gewinn, der es dann hat. Wir können jetzt darüber diskutieren, was das über die Qualität einzeln und rein aussagt.
Ich weiß nicht, wer ich da eingerätscht habe. Ich finde es heute interessant, erstens mal, weil diese Leistungsdichte ja anscheinend zu eng ist, dass die Vereine sich ja anscheinend alle irgendwo so ähnlich sind, also entweder gleich gut oder gleich schlecht, je nachdem, vor welchem Blickwinkel man das betrachten möchte. Man sieht ja auch in Liga 2 oder in Liga 1, dass sich die Aufsteige dementsprechend schwer tun, wenn man mich nicht versteht mit dem Dialekt, übrigens bitte sagen. Ansonsten denke ich, ist es einfach auch spannend zu beobachten, dass eben auch ähnlich wie in der ersten Liga vielleicht auch Vereine, die jetzt eher unten waren, die ganze Zeit auch mal ein bisschen nach oben schauen. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte nicht gedacht, dass Kaiserslautern momentan dritter ist oder, dass Hannover sich doch diesmal so gut um Aufstieg mit schlägt oder, dass Darmstadt so weit unten ist. Also von der Gut Schalke war erwartbar, aber es ist schon irgendwo das auch mal interessant zu sehen, dass da vielleicht momentan so ein bisschen eine Wandlust stattfindet, dass vielleicht manche Strategien von manchen Vereinen endlich fruchten und manche aber halt wiederum nicht oder ja auf der Stelle treten. Das finde ich zumindest auch spannend zu beobachten, in der Halbzeit Liga auch.
Also ich finde es auch, weil du jetzt gerade Darmstadt erwähnt hast, weil die standen ja am Anfang ganz unten, aber die haben es jetzt irgendwie geschafft, so bevor sich diese Tabelle so aufgesplittet hat, so in dieses obere Tabellenfeld reinzuspielen. Also bei denen hat ja jetzt glaube ich im Moment keine akute Abstiegsangst. Aber es liegt halt auch daran, dass diese Tabelle halt irgendwo so einen Cut hat und wo dann irgendwie fünf Punkte sind oder was und dann geht es nach unten. Und da hat Darmstadt irgendwie rechtzeitig so unten den Absprung geschafft irgendwie. Das ist schon krass.
Ja, es gibt ja immer das beliebte Wort die Kohfeldtabelle. Da sind sie ja, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall relativ weit oben mit dabei. Das finde ich auch krass. Also ich glaube, das sagen wir eh seit Jahren. Also dieses Thema, wenn du mal einen Lauf in der Liga hast, kann das mal was ganz anderes bedeuten. Gleichzeitig bei Nürnberg, ja. Die hatten vor allem so nach dem Derby diesen Ausstieg. Aber sie haben jetzt zuletzt eben in Paderborn oder jetzt auch gegen Düsseldorf eben es zweimal nicht geschafft, ihre Führung über die Zeit zu bringen. Und kassieren dann eben zweimal den Ausgleich und es sind dann halt vier verlorene Punkte. Und das siehst du dann halt sofort in der Tabelle. Und das finde ich halt so krass. Also wirklich dieses, ja, das wird bestraft, nicht erst am Ende der Saison, sondern das wird direkt an dem Spieltag bestraft. Und ich finde es deshalb so schwierig, irgendwelche Prognosen abzusetzen. Also irgendwie bei Fortuna Düsseldorf, wenn man nur so verfolgt, was Fans und Co irgendwie schreiben, und dann denkst du, die sind irgendwie 8 Punkte Abstand auf einem Aufstiegsplatz. Und dann wurde ja jetzt, sie haben mit Daniel Tune verlängert vorzeitig so, gerade in diese Phase rein, wo sie ja unter anderem gegen Elversberg verloren haben, jetzt auch wieder, ja, dieses 2-2 gegen Nürnberg war auch ein bisschen wild, also auch mit einem Elfmeter, der wiederholt wurde, Kastenmeier hält zweimal, also da war viel auch dabei. Aber sie haben halt, ja, also, das ist auch ein wichtiges Zeichen, aber das zeigt halt auch nochmal manchmal, dass Fans sowas natürlich auch anders sehen. Aber klar ist natürlich, Düsseldorf hat so einen gewissen Anspruch nach letzter Saison, aber gleichzeitig, also ich möchte momentan kein Entscheider bei keinem dieser Club sein, weil wir ja eben sehen, hab mal drei gute Spiele und in der Theorie kann bei Dreiviertel der Tabelle oder eigentlich ja auch in der ganzen Liga deine Situation komplett anders aussehen. Und das macht es für uns vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen schwieriger, wirklich da irgendwie zu sagen so, hey, lass mal einen, weiß ich nicht, Hinrunden-Fazit ziehen und du kriegst auf die Tabelle nur eine halbe Liga kann aufsteigen. Geht cool.
Und bei der Theorie ist halt auch da nochmal das, spannend einzuhelfen, dass du sagst, wenn du jetzt die Tabelle umdrehst, da ist ja nicht viel anders. Also ich weiß, wir sind Letzte mit 8 Punkten, aber jetzt, wenn wir von der Theorie heute zweimal gewinnen würden, könnten wir, wenn jetzt Braunschweig alles verliert in der Zwischenzeit, Braunschweig überholen. Was halt jetzt in dem Fall für viele, die unten am Tabellende stehen, und damit, das meine ich jetzt nicht nur den Jahn, sondern vielleicht auch Ulm, Münster und so weiter, halt schwierig ist das vor allem gegen die direkten Konkurrenten oder so entscheidende Partien. Wie gesagt, Regensburg-Schalke war so ein Spiel, da schaffts halt zum Beispiel an der Jahn nicht zu punkten. Dann würdest du unten ja auch nochmal viel mehr Bewegung sehen. Das heißt, nur die, die am Tabellenende sind, die bleiben sich in der Theorie etwas treu. Aber da hättest du auch von der Theorie her viel mehr Bewegung, wenn es da halt einen oder anderen Lucky Punch gegeben hätte. Und wie gesagt, du bist da denke ich auch viel schneller drin.
Das ist auch für die Teams unten, wenn die mal einen Unentschieden holen gegen ein Team von oben, das ist also ein Punkt allein, ist so viel wert momentan im Tabellenkeller, weil du durch einen Punkt allein schon immer so ein bisschen klettern kannst, wenn deine Mitkonkurrenten verlieren. Das ist krass.
Einfach um das nur noch mal kurz so darzustellen, weil ich ja gerade noch mal da hab, wenn du überlegst, hätten wir jetzt gewonnen, dann wären wir zwar jetzt nicht an Schalke vorbei, aber dann wären wir ein bis zwei Punkte hinter Schalke. Was meinst du, wie da der Baum brennt? Ja. Also gut, da brennt der Baum sowieso. Oder auch bei Führte oder so. Das kann ja niemals der Anspruch sein. Aber na ja.
Ja, aber das meine ich eben auch. Das ist halt so schwierig, wirklich zu sagen, ab wann gehen wir vielleicht auch mit dem Punkt Trainerentlassung. Ich glaube, dieses Winter-Transfer-Fenster wird für so viele Vereine so enorm wichtig, weil du musst einfach aus dieser Winterpause gut rauskommen. Wir haben es zum Beispiel bei Braunschweig letzte Saison gesehen. Also ich stand hier vor einem Jahr und habe felsenfest gesagt, Braunschweig wird sich da nie raus wurschteln. Ich meine, sie sind da nicht mit 15 Punkten Abstand rausgekommen, aber sie sind eben rausgekommen, obwohl deren Lage ja schon ziemlich dunkel aussah damals gemeinsam mit Osnabrück. Und das finde ich schon interessant, dass es auch gerade im Tabellenkeller doch immer wieder diese Automatismen gibt am Ende. Aber ja, ich glaube, da kann man auch sehr lange drüber reden, weil das ist einfach– also ich meine, HSV würde ich jetzt so ein bisschen ausklammern gerade, weil wir eben noch nicht wissen, ob der schöne Bruno kommt. Ich hoffe, für alle HSV-Fans auch nicht. Es ist ja eventuell so– und das fände ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr interessant– Merlin Polzin soll ja auf jeden Fall gegen Darmstadt Trainer sein am Wochenende. Und ich würde fast auch Kunst wünschen und Co., dass sie wirklich den Weg gehen. Weil ich glaube, wenn man so Stimmen hat, ist schon ein sehr interessantes Trainertalent. Und sie haben ja jetzt in den letzten Jahren irgendwie alles einmal durchprobiert, muss man ja einfach sagen. Und vielleicht ist dann– also Polzin ist ja jetzt auch nicht dein klassischer Interimstrainer, sondern der hat ja durchaus auch die Qualifikation. Und da bin ich schon sehr gespannt, was der HSV da jetzt für einen Weg geht. Weil ich sage es auch gerne nochmal, diese Gags sind auch irgendwann einfach nicht mehr lustig. Also es ist auch einfach irgendwie, ja, ein bisschen tragisch. Obwohl sie jetzt auch– also es ist immer so ein bisschen ironisch, wenn man sieht, sie stehen trotzdem auf Platz zwei und auch da wird ein Szenario gemalt, als wäre man irgendwie Vorletzter. Aber gut. Aber lass uns dann noch tatsächlich auf den ersten von diesen beiden Vereinen in dieser Besprechung gehen, auf die SV Elversberg. Sie steht auf Platz sechs, 22 Punkte, 25 zu 17 Tore, sechs Siege, vier unentschieden viele Niederlagen und man ist punktgleich mit Fortuna Köln, genau, mit dem FC Köln und Fortuna Düsseldorf. Ei, ei, ei. Das liest sich ja schon mal ganz gut. Vor allem hat man eben das bessere Punktverhältnis, Torverhältnis und ist deshalb eben über den beiden. Es gab am Wochenende zwar eine 3 zu 1 Niederlage gegen Paderborn, aber ich habe eben schon mal angesprochen, sehr absurder November irgendwie. Es gab nämlich unter anderem Siege gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf und Anova 96. Jonas, nimm uns doch mal gerade mit, wie sieht es denn aus bei der SVE gerade?
Ja, also, wie du es schon gesagt hast, der November war schon krass, was die Ergebnisse angeht. Aber jetzt diese Niederlage gegen Paderborn, die lässt da jetzt nichts einbrechen. Also diese Siege, die nimmt man zwar mit, aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, ja jetzt will man unbedingt oben mitspielen oder jetzt ist man da irgendwie in der Tabelle, wo man sich sieht oder so. Das nimmt man halt alles mit. Und es war vor dem Spiel gegen Paderborn so. Da waren es aus meiner Sicht 11 Punkte Abstand auf Ulm. Und jetzt sind es nach der Niederlage gegen Paderborn, sind es jetzt noch 10 Punkte Abstand auf Ulm. Also der Blick ist schon immer Richtung unterer Relegationsrang, weil und das hat sich im letzten Jahr eben auch gezeigt. Umso früher du deine Punkte zusammen hast, umso ruhiger wird es am Schluss. Also in der letzten Saison war es auch so, man hat fünf Spiele gebraucht und dann hat man fleißig Punkte gesammelt und das hat am Schluss hinten raus dann einfach gereicht. Und das ist, denke ich, gerade wenn wir jetzt sehen, im Tabellenkeller hängt alles so zusammen und keiner kommt irgendwie richtig raus. Dann ist es nochmal umso wichtiger, wenn du sagst, okay, am Anfang viele Punkte sammeln, alles mitnehmen, was geht. Ob das ein Sieg gegen Hannover, gegen Düsseldorf oder auch am Anfang von der Saison nur ein Punkt gegen Köln. Das nimmst du alles mit und davon zählst du dann gegen Ende der Saison. Weil man muss einfach sagen, das ist eine junge Mannschaft, da sind viele junge Spieler, die sich entwickeln wollen und auch können. Und dann musst du denen einfach auch zugestehen, dass die mal so ein 3-1 gegen Paderborn kassieren. Oder auch mal ein 1-0 gegen Regensburg oder ein 3-1 gegen Ulm. Das sind dann so Spiele, die, sag mal, gegen Regensburg und Ulm, da hat man sich schon eher was ausgerechnet. Aber das ist dann aufgrund der Siege dann schon verschmerzbar.
Naja, das ist so, ja.
Ja, sag gerne, Thomas.
Ja, das, also wie gesagt, das, das gegen Regensburg, das aber das Witzige war, vor dem Spiel in Regensburg, weil also ich gehe jetzt seit 2011 nach Elversberg und ich weiß, wie in Elversberg die Ergebnisse aussehen. Und ich habe vorm Spiel in Regensburg habe ich gesagt, jetzt zu verlieren, das wäre so typisch Elversberg. Und zack, 1-0 verloren. Super, super kombiniert, vorne nicht durchgekommen. Dann verlierst du halt einfach. So, dass aber das, und das gegen Ulm, wir haben lange in der Regionalliga immer gegen Ulm gespielt. Und Duelle gegen Ulm, Hessen, Kassel, Offenbach und Mannheim waren immer eklig. Und da habe ich vorm Spiel, das war ein Heimspiel ja gegen Ulm, habe ich vorm Spiel gesagt, würde es nicht wundern, wenn man das heute verliert. Zack, 3-1 verloren. Also, wie gesagt, das muss man der Mannschaft, muss man das schon zugestehen. Und wie gesagt, wenn dann die anderen Ergebnisse so kommen, dann ist das natürlich weniger schlimm.
Naja, und das ist natürlich auch die Situation, also gegen die Aussteiger sind es immer andere Spiele. Von dir wird natürlich, also klar ist die SVE jetzt nicht der typische Zweitligist aus den letzten Jahren, aber trotzdem ja einer, der es eben geschafft hat. Und dann wird natürlich trotzdem, man muss trotzdem erst mal das Spiel machen, ne? Weil also ein Regensburg und auch ein Ulm sagen erst mal, naja, dann macht ihr doch mal und zeigt uns mal, wie ihr in der Liga geblieben seid, so. Und da ist natürlich ja die Erwartungshaltung eine ganz andere, als wenn man halt auswärts, zum Beispiel bei einem ausverkauften Düsseldorfer Stadion spielt oder so. Das ist ja eine ganz andere Voraussetzung. Und man muss ja auch wirklich sagen, also diesen Platz zu haben, trotz ja gar nicht so unwichtiger Spieler, die fehlen. Also es gibt ja schon ein paar Verletzungen. Luca Schnellbacher, Florian Lejeancourt, gerade der, ich glaube, war das Spiel gegen Darmstadt, wo er sich so böse den Ellenbogen verletzt hat.
Das, ja, der hat sich da alle Binder im Arm abgelassen.
Der ja, glaube ich, jetzt wieder im Kader stand, zumindest gegen Paderborn, genau wie Schnellbacher. Aber man, glaube ich, gesagt hat, nee, das schont man zumindest trotzdem. Aber ist natürlich trotzdem ein gutes Zeichen. Auch sagt gerne um was zur Rolle von Semis Shaheen. Ich glaube, der hat ja Wadenprobleme schon. Da ist unbekannt, wann er zurückkehrt. Auch der gerade, glaube ich, zumindest zwei Tore, ein Assist fehlt seit dem neunten Spieltag. Da ist ja auch irgendwie so jemand Wichtiges einfach für die Vereinsstufe oder die Kaderstruktur weg.
Ja, aber das war ja schon vor der Saison, als klar war okay. Von der Mäsch geht wieder zurück nach K. Van Aert geht natürlich weg und Rochelt wurde dann noch weggekauft. Das war dann so, okay, das waren drei sehr gute. Und die musste man dann erstmal ersetzen. Dann wusste man, okay, Fredde Jäckel, der hat einen Kreuzbandriss. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch nichts mit Saisonstart und Anfang. Und dann hat man halt Elversberg-Dinge gemacht. Man hat jemanden aus der Regionalliga Südwest gekauft. Man hat sich zwei Leute von Hoffenheim II geliehen. Man hat noch jemanden von Eintracht Frankfurt geliehen. Und das waren alles oder sind alles junge Spieler. Und bei denen war bei allen die Marschrote. Hier kommt ihr her und könnt euch hier entwickeln. Und das hat mal wieder funktioniert, muss man sagen. Und deswegen, klar, so ein Semischain, der tut schon weh im Mittelfeld, weil er vor allen Dingen auch das Spiel halt aus der Mitte raus antreibt. Und diese Qualität haben im Kader jetzt nicht so viele. Aber das wurde dann wieder über das Kollektiv irgendwie aufgefangen. Und da ist mir dann auch wieder so ein Satz aufgepoppt, den hat Uwe Burg von ein paar Jahren mal gesagt, da wurde befragt, wie sucht sich Elversberg die Spieler aus? Und da hat er unter anderem gesagt, ja, also wir gucken zwar schon auch auf die Qualität, aber es muss auf jeden Fall menschlich passen. So, und das ist das, was du immer wieder aus der Mannschaft hörst. Dass jeder für den anderen läuft. Und nur dann, wenn jeder dem anderen irgendwie zur Seite steht, nur dann kannst du diese Ausfälle auch aufgreifen. Also zum Beispiel Manuel Pfeil, der spielt dann halt mal eine Zeit lang nicht. Dann spielt er mal wieder, dann spielt er mal nicht. Aber das ist dann okay, der ist jetzt auch seit 2018 da. Der kennt Horst Steffen, der weiß, wie das System funktioniert. Und bei den anderen, bei den Jungen, denen wird dann Zeit gegeben. Also ich weiß noch die ersten vier Spiele von Elias Baum. Er ist der ausgeliehene Rechtsverteidiger von Eintracht Frankfurt. Du siehst den Jungen an, dass die so ein bisschen brauchen, in dieses System von Horst Steffen reinzukommen. Gerade die Verteidiger. Ich habe so einen kleinen Verteidiger-Fetisch. Und das war bei Elias Baum so, und das war bei Freddy Jäckl in der letzten Saison genauso. Die brauchen ein bisschen, bis die das System von Horst Steffen verstanden haben, dass die mit antreiben. Und das war bei Elias Baum ganz witzig zu sehen. Erst an den ersten Spielen ist er nicht nach vorne gerannt. Sondern nur hinten stehen geblieben. Dann hat Horst Jeff wahrscheinlich gesagt, treib mit an. Er konnte es dann auch bei Maurice Neubauer auf der anderen Seite sehen. Da ist er irgendwann nach vorne gerannt und ist nicht mehr zurückgekommen. Aber jetzt hat er sich top entwickelt. Er ist ein so guter Baustein. Und eben diese Außenverteidiger im System von Horst Steffen, die braucht es einfach. Deswegen lassen sich dann auch so Sachen wie Semmi Sahin oder jetzt, wenn Luca Schnellbach auch mal ausgefallen ist, bei einem Fisnikas Lani einfach auch die Zeit bekommen hat, sich da zu entwickeln. Das ist einfach dieser fehlende Druck, den die Jungs da haben. Und dann können die auch dann mal so ein, zwei Spiele, wo es dann vielleicht nicht so funktioniert, einfach so wegstecken, ohne dass da irgendwie dann eine tiefe Sinneskrise entsteht.
Siehst du denn generell eine Gefahr in– also fällt ja schon auf, es sind viele Leihgeschäfte– siehst du da in irgendeinem Jahr vielleicht eine Gefahr, dass das dann irgendwann doch mal zum Ende der Saison, also dass man irgendwann diesen Ersatz vielleicht nicht mehr holen kann. Also ich gehe jetzt nicht davon aus, dass dann irgendwie dann mal das Geld ganz viel in die Hand genommen wird bei drei Leihspielern und es wird gesagt, hier ja, komm, bleib mal. Weil korrigiere mich gerne, wenn ich da falsch liege. Also klar, es ist natürlich eine Auszeichnung, wo natürlich auch wir so wie Horst Steffen arbeiten will. Das hast du uns, glaube ich, letztes Jahr auch schon erklärt oder nicht letztes Jahr, ich glaube, es war im Frühjahr. Ist auch egal. Da hast du uns das ja auch schon so ein bisschen erklärt, dass es so der Weg ist. Aber es gibt ja schon noch mal einen Unterschied zwischen, ja, okay, wir sind jetzt im ersten Jahr zweite Liga. Wir müssen erstmal schauen, was brauchen wir vielleicht auch an Qualität und menschlich und jetzt bis zum zweiten Jahr. Und dann sagt man ja schon, okay, also wir gucken jetzt nicht immer halt nach unten. So man will sich natürlich wahrscheinlich schon irgendwann in der Liga etablieren. Und das geht ja wahrscheinlich auf lange Sicht auch dann schon mit so einem Stammkader, der dann auch mal bestehen bleibt über ein, zwei Saisons.
Ja, also ich sag mal, diese Line, das ist natürlich jetzt ein Modell, das man in den letzten drei Jahren sehr erfolgreich gefahren hat. Das hat schon in der 3. Liga mit Nick Voltemade angefangen. Und da ist natürlich die Gefahr, dass wenn man sagt, okay, man gibt, weil man muss ja einfach sagen, die letzten, also in der 3. Liga war es Nick Voltemade. In der letzten Saison war es Paul Wanner. Das sind einfach Leihspieler, die dann am Schluss gehen und den Riesenimpact hatten vorher. Es ist aber schon so, also das ist ja schon eine Achse da aus Spielern, die außenrum sind. Also ob das jetzt Nikolas Christoph, der Torhüter, ist. Und dann geht es außenrum über Maurice Neubauer, Manuel Pfeil, Semih Sahin, vorne Lukas Schnellbacher. Die bieten so ein bisschen das Gerüst für diese Laien. Klar ist aber auch, man hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen Ruf gemacht, dass sich Laien gut entwickeln können. Aber es ist halt schon schwierig, wenn man irgendwann mal an den Punkt kommt, wo man vielleicht nicht die Laie bekommt, die man sich erhofft hat. Und der Verein hängt da schon noch so ein bisschen hinten dran, weil es so schnell ging, auch das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum und die zweite Mannschaft so ran zu ziehen, dass du sagen kannst, okay, da kann vielleicht auch von unten irgendwie was aufgefangen werden. Da ist schon noch so, dass das so ein bisschen hinten dran hängt. Aber ich sag mal, so im Moment denkt da dran, in Elversberg natürlich keiner. Das ist ja, aber wie gesagt, im Spiel sieht man es schon auch, wenn Leihspieler neu da sind, dann hast du mit Luca Schnellwacher zum Beispiel jemanden, der auch in der Rückwärtsbewegung immer sehr viel arbeitet und viele Lücken zuläuft, weil die Leihspieler eben ins System reinkommen müssen. Das wäre natürlich anders, wenn du sag ich mal einen größeren oder einen breiteren Stamm hättest, den du immer einsetzen könntest. Aber ich glaube also, dieses Etablieren in der Liga, das wird jetzt auch nicht– also in der nächsten Saison wird man jetzt nicht sagen, wir sind etablierter Zweitligist und müssen irgendwie einen schönen Tabellenplatz erreichen, sondern ich gehe mal schwer davon aus, dass es auch in der nächsten Saison heißt, es geht gegen den Abstieg. Und der Druck nimmt da jetzt in Elversberg nicht unbedingt zu.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil ihr da so lange jetzt über die Leihspieler gesprochen habt, habe ich jetzt mal im Hintergrund so ein bisschen geschaut, wie das denn bei uns so war mit den Leihspielern. Und wir hatten ja im Abstiegsjahr auch ein großes Problem, weil wir ja so viele Leihspieler hatten. Und ich kann nur sagen, wenn ich mir diese Historie von uns zum Beispiel auch anschaue, denke ich, dass Leihspieler vor allem einfach auch dann eher ein Problem sind, wenn sie halt einfach nicht richtig funktionieren. Also wenn ich so in die früheren Jahre schaue, da haben wir Maxi Thal, Adrian Fein, Sebastian Stolze, Thal haben wir mit seiner ersten Zeit bei uns, Gimel mit seiner ersten Zeit bei uns, Joshua Maes, die haben halt auch alle funktioniert, die waren gut. Und bei uns kamen halt dann irgendwo immer so Leihen, so ein Niklas Schipnowski zum Beispiel, der wo du halt sagen musst, ich will ihm jetzt nichts Böses sagen, Gott will ihn, aber es hat halt nicht so funktioniert, wie sie das wahrscheinlich beide Seiten gedacht hatten. Und wir haben halt nicht immer nur Glück gehabt, wie mit dem Jahn-Niklas-Best oder Oskar Schönfelde oder Sabrit Singh in der ersten Version. Und ich glaube, das ist halt die große Gefahr bei Leihspielen, du verlässt dich halt auf welche, und wenn es nicht läuft und die wieder weg sind, dann sind sie halt ein Gefahrenherd. Aber wenn sie funktionieren, und das tun sie ja bei euch anscheinend, dann macht man sich halt da keine Gedanken, das ist das Risiko, was du halt einfach hast.
Ja, also, das ist halt, ich sag mal, man hatte jetzt auch immer Glück. In der letzten Saison bei den Innenverteidigern, dann hat man Florian de Jongcourt nachverpflichtet, und der hat da direkt eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe. Und jetzt hattest du halt den Ausfall von ihm, und auf einmal spielt Lukas Pinkert Innenverteidiger, als hätte er nie was anderes gemacht in seinem Leben. Da hattest du auch schon Glück so mit den Leistungssteigerungen von den Spielern, die schon dran waren. Man hatte jetzt auch Glück, dass man vor der Saison auch Tom Zimmerschied verpflichtet, also nicht geliehen, sondern verpflichtet. Und da hat man jetzt gerade Glück, dass man den halt jetzt wieder auf den Flügel einsetzen kann, wo man auf dem Flügel halt Bedarf hat. Und man muss schon sagen, man hat in den letzten Jahren gut geplant, aber man hatte auch schon Glück, dass alles genauso funktioniert hat. Aber dessen ist man auch schon sich bewusst in Elversberg, dass da natürlich Glück mit dabei war, dass das so funktioniert hat.
Ich musste übrigens bei Tom Zimmerchit sehr schmunzeln, weil er beim Spiel gegen uns ergspielt und er hatte bei Dresden schon keine Chance bei uns reingemacht letzte Saison und das hat er hier nahtlos fortgesetzt. Also danke, Tom Zimmerchit, falls du zugehört bist, geh ich ja uns gern weiter so. Aber das ist eher mehr Zufall. Ich würde da gerne noch bei einer Sache kurz einhaken, um das noch mal kurz zu untermauern, weil ich es gerade noch mal gesehen habe, weil ich ja auch, wie gesagt, Eva kennen ja den Niklas erwähnt habe. Wir hatten eben zu der Zeit, als Schipnowski zu uns gekommen hat, wir zum Beispiel Jan Nikolas Bestin. Du hast schon gemerkt, das soll so der fließende Übergang sein, für Beste, der dann umgeschult worden ist, kam dann Schipnowski. Ich meine, wo die Geschichten hingegangen sind, müssen wir jetzt nicht drüber sprechen. Der eine ist bei Benfica, der andere ist bei Waldhof Mannheim.
Das ist die Hauptsache Italien oder so.
Ich glaube, das soll wirklich nicht despektivlich gemeint sein, um das halt nur mal so hervorzuheben, was das halt ausmachen kann. Weil ich meine, da verlässt du dich heute natürlich drauf.
Naja, und ich glaube, was da gar nicht so unwichtig ist, ist halt wirklich so eine Spielidee auch zu haben. Also wenn wir jetzt bei Schipnowski sind, also ich weiß, zum Beispiel in Bielefeld war das auch, da hatte man so spät natürlich erst Trainer und Crew zusammen, da hattest du gar nicht die Freiheiten, wirklich nach Spielidee eins zu eins einzukaufen oder auch dir die Spieler zusammenzusuchen, sag ich mal so. Und also sag mir gerne, wenn der Vergleich einfach ein bisschen low-hanging fruit ist, aber ich finde halt schon, also so ein bisschen von der Transferstrategie passend zum Trainer, es wird so ein bisschen wie Heidenheim. Also auch im Sinne von, also es ist keine 1 zu 1 Kopie, aber auch bei Heidenheim wusste man ja immer, da werden ja, egal von wo der Spieler kam, wichtig war, ist, er muss gewisse Basics einfach mit drin haben, er muss spielerisch zur Mannschaft passen, aber eben auch menschlich und einfach vom, ohne dass dann jetzt immer der beste Spieler aus der Regionalliga oder so geholt wurde, aber sondern einfach, dass das passt und das eben auch vielleicht mit Leiden zu starten etc. Und ich glaube halt einfach, also man muss ja am Ende sagen, Elversberg ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der Verein Nummer 1, in dem man geht, aber gleichzeitig hat er ja den unglaublichen Vorteil, dass man eben auch in Ruhe junge Spieler entwickeln kann. Also da wird nicht jeder, jedes junge Talent sofort zum, weiß ich nicht, nächsten U17-Star hochgejässt oder so, sondern es wird halt wirklich gesagt, hey, die sollen ja erst mal reinpassen und dann gucken wir mal weiter. Und ich glaube, das ist einfach, das sehen dann eben auch, ich glaube, das hatten wir letztes Mal auch schon angesprochen, das sehen natürlich auch andere Vereine, dass das einfach ein ganz großer Vorteil ist, da Spieler weiterzuentwickeln.
Ja, also das ist halt auch diese Erfahrung, Spieler deswegen zu nehmen, weil sie irgendwie einen Namen haben oder irgendwie sonst wo irgendwie was geleistet haben. Die Erfahrung hat man in Elversberg auch schon gemacht. Also man ist ja 2013, sind wir ja das erste Mal in die dritte Liga aufgestiegen und da hat man in der Winterpause damals versucht, mit Ondrijs Metterner irgendwie noch die Kohlen ins Trockene zu bringen, nur weil der irgendwie mal neuen Spiele für Hansa Rostock oder so was gemacht hat und keine Ahnung, 2,9 Meter groß ist, damit er irgendwie ein paar Tore reinköpft. Und dann in der Folge hat man immer, dann hat man mal Edmund Kaplani hat da gespielt, Milan Ivana hat hier gespielt, dann wurden auch Trainer dann nach dem Namen geholt, dann Michael Wiesinger hat hier trainiert, Carsten Neitzel. Das war alles so ein bisschen, ja, wir holen uns jetzt das, was irgendwie schon mal ein Name hatte oder so. Und als man dann mehrere Jahre in der Regionalliga einfach mit diesem Weg nicht weitergekommen ist, da hat dann ein Umdenken stattgefunden. Und dann 2018 eben mit Horst Steffen und Ole Borg dann dieser neue Weg eingeschlagen wurde. Ich glaube, da hat man schon daraus gelernt, dass eben das Scouting und die Spieler, die kommen, die müssen einfach in dieses System passen und über die Kontinuität schaffst du es dann, so Leistungen abzurufen. Weil die Mannschaft, die jetzt in Elversberg spielt, die würde ja niemand so zusammenkaufen, wenn man einem sagen würde, spiel eine Saison Zweite Liga. Da wird ja niemand diese Namen aufstellen. Also das ist halt einfach so die Kontinuität, die da ist. Und dann eben dieses Zusammenspiel aus Horst Steffen und Ole Bog, der eben genau weiß, was für Spieler Horst Steffen braucht. Und ja, das wie gesagt, dann in Kombination mit dem Glück, das wir in den letzten Jahren hatten, dann kommt das dabei raus.
Lass uns mal ganz kurz bei Horst Steffen bleiben. Also, wenn ich jetzt einfach mal auf die bisherigen Spiele gucke, habe ich schon so das Gefühl, er spielt ja, korrigiere mich, wenn ich da falsch liege, immer noch weiterhin mit einer Viererkette hinten und dann meistens entweder so einem 3-2-1 oder 4-2 mit Doppel-6. Ich hatte das, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hatte er letzte Saison schon auch zwischendurch mal versucht, irgendwie mal auf Dreierkette oder so zu gehen. Hast du das Gefühl, er lässt dir zu wenig, also ich möchte es in ganz großen Anführungsstrichen an Experimente sagen, dass er die so ein bisschen gestoppt hat, weil er auch wirklich gesagt hat, naja, das ist die Formation, mit der ich wirklich am erfolgreichsten bin, wo ich trotzdem noch ein bisschen variabel drin bin, aber so ich stelle mich jetzt nicht jede Woche mit einer anderen Formation gegen den Gegner drauf ein.
Ja, also diese Viererkette hinten, die ist schon sehr gesetzt bei ihm, weil eben dieser Aufbau über die zwei Außenverteidiger, das ist schon das, was er auch sehen will. Und diese Außenläufe bei Maurice Neubau und Elias Baum, die kommen auch den Spielern entgegen. In der 3. Liga hat er damals gegen 1860, die hat er komplett überrumpelt mit einer Dreierkette. Und damals hat er schon gesagt, auch wenn sie oft dasselbe System spielen, ihm ist es einfach wichtig, dass die Spieler zwei Systeme können. Dass die Spieler zwei Systeme können, heißt ja aber nicht, dass der immer wechselt. Deswegen würde ich schon sagen, diese Viererkette und dann, ob das jetzt ein 4-2-3-1 oder manchmal auch mit Schnellbacher und Aslani vorne oder in der letzten Saison hat er auch oft immer ein Stock so leicht hinter Schnellbacher stehen gehabt. Das ist dann spielabhängig, aber dieser Grundaufbau über die Viererkette, das ist schon was, das ist festgesetzt fast. Also wenn da nicht größere Ausfälle sind, wenn er also nicht verletzungsbedingt umstellen muss, dann ist das eigentlich fast so.
Es gäbe dir schon so ein Problemfeld, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, wenn ich von außen drauf gucke und das ist bei den Gegentoren, die die nach Standard fallen. Du lachst schon.
Ja, du sprichst was an, was Elversberg-Fans seit, also seit Horst Steffen eigentlich da ist, ist das Thema.
Okay, also du würdest schon sagen, dass es generell was, was irgendwie, was man nicht ganz rauskriegt, das würdest du jetzt nicht per se irgendwie auch an den Verletzungen von Le Jean-Cour und Jäkel festmachen, dass da einfach, ich sag jetzt mal, zwei große Spiele herab fehlen?
Nee, also dass diese, die Standardschwäche bei eigenen Standards, wohlgemerkt, und die Standardschwäche bei gegnerischen Standards, das ist was, also das ist schon seit der Regionalliga, ist das eigentlich schon drin. Das ist so ein Thema, das nimmt man immer mit. Und das war dann auch schön zu sehen, als dann so vor der Saison hat Horst Steffen dann auch gesagt, ja, wir haben an den Standards gearbeitet und dass wir uns da verbessern. Dann spielst du das erste Heimspiel gegen Köln und hast, glaube ich, 13 Eckbälle gegen dich. Das war so, okay, wir gucken jetzt, ob diese Zahnstocherbrücke funktioniert und dann stellen wir ein LKW drauf. Und dann hast du auch direkt natürlich von Hübers dann Gegentour kassiert. Also, es ist regelmäßig so, wenn wir Spiele schauen im Stadion und der Gegner kriegt eine Ecke, dann sagen wir immer schon, fuck. Also, weil das ist halt meistens super gefährlich. Und das ist jetzt gar nicht mal am Wochenende gegen Paderborn. Na klar, 45. Ecken, Gegentor, direkt abgepfiffen danach. Das passt natürlich total gut. Aber das sind auch dann Freistöße und so. Das war auch gegen Ulm ja auch die Niederlage. Das waren auch Standards. So, das ist halt einfach eine Schwäche. Ja, die wird halt gefühlt als Fan wird sie so ein bisschen stiefenmütterlich behandelt. Im Verein ist das sicherlich anders. Aber es ist halt einfach ein Problem, das kriegst du halt nicht so richtig raus. Und halt auch das eine Problem sind die Gegentore. Aber das andere ist halt auch, dass du nach eigenen Ecken einfach völlig ungefährlich bist. Also ich glaube, die haben 80 Ecken oder so und kein Tor. Also das ist halt völliger Wahnsinn.
Also ich glaube, laut WhoScore, das ist zumindest ein Standard-Tor. Aber Standard heißt natürlich auch Freistöße. Also ja, also ich kann übrigens nicht empfehlen, sich dann einen Standard-Trainer zu holen. Bedeutet nicht immer Besserung. Liebe Grüße an der Stelle nochmal an Ilja Gruev. Davon hat sich ja Mia Bielefeld, glaube ich, zweieinhalb Jahre nicht erholt. Nein, aber ich glaube, also ich finde es halt schon immer interessant, weil man sagt ja immer so schön, manchmal bei Vereinen, die vielleicht schon gut spielerisch was mitbringen, aber vielleicht einfach in gewissem Rahmen dann auch einfach limitiert sind, Standard hat immer ein guter Trick. Und gleichzeitig ist es halt manchmal auch ein großes Problem, das eben zu verteidigen. Und manchmal ist ja wirklich so das Einzige, also gerade bei Gegentoren, aber eben auch selber, welche zu erziehen sind, einfach groß gewachsene Menschen. Es ist, also das ist halt tatsächlich erst mal kein wahnsinnig neuer Take, aber es ist ja so.
Ja, aber die Erfahrung, die haben wir in der dritten Liga gemacht. Also da dachten wir auch, als Nick Voltemade kam, dachten wir, cool, jetzt haben wir jemanden. Und dann haben wir gemerkt, okay, der weiß, wie er den Fuß mit dem Ball spielt, aber mit dem Kopf wird es schwer. Der war auch völlig ungefährlich. Der hatte auch kein richtig gutes Timing beim Kopfball. Und der hat dann ein Kopfballtor gemacht in Duisburg. Und da wurde er mehr angeschossen. Ihm wurde mehr der Ball gegen den Kopf geschossen und dann flog er ins Tor. Also dieses, ja, große Spieler. Und dann wird das schon, dass dieses Automat, diesen Automatismus, an den glaubten wir auch, der hat sich aber nicht so richtig bewahrheitet. Wobei man schon sagen muss, also durch die Verpflichtung von Florian Lejeancourt, der auch eine gewisse Körperlichkeit im Gegensatz zu Nick Woltemade in der Sache mitbringt, da wurde es schon besser. Also man war in der 3. Liga, war man schon eine der kleinsten Mannschaften, so was den Durchschnitt angeht. Aber da ist natürlich Recht. Also wenn du, wenn du große Leute hinten drin hast, die eine gewisse Körperlichkeit haben, am besten noch Innenverteidiger, die wissen, wie sie ordentlich in Zweikampf gehen, dann ist das schon eine gute Basis, sage ich mal, dafür. Deswegen, wir warten, am Wochenende war, als Florian ins Stadion kamen, haben alle seinen Namen gerufen. Also der wird sehnlichst zurückerwartet, genauso wie Frendi Jäckel, weil man diese großen Leute, gut, man hat noch Maximilian Rohr, aber diese großen Leute hinten drin, die will man schon sehen.
Eine letzte Sache noch, bevor wir gleich zum anderen Verein wechseln, das Finanzielle bei Elversberg. Also wenn ich jetzt, liebe Grüße an den Transfermarkt wie ich, weiß, dass ist immer mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber es ist leider trotzdem irgendwie noch so die einfachste Übersicht. Man hat ja ca. 1,5 Millionen für Jannik Rochelt bekommen, der ist dann zu Hannover 96 gewechselt. Und man bezahlt, glaube ich, nur Leihgebühren für drei Spieler. Also es ist jetzt, wenn ich so, oder zumindest für zwei Spieler, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, hat an sich erstmal ein Transfer plus. Aber wie sieht es denn sonst finanziell bei der SVE aus? Also wie ist es mit Stadionfinanzierung etc.?
Also man muss ja sagen, für all die, die sich jetzt gar nicht auskennen, auch bei Elversberg gibt es einen Investor. Das ist ein ehemaliger Bundesligaspieler Frank Holzer, der nach seiner Bundesliga-Karriere sich in die Pharmazie begeben hat und ein Pharmaunternehmen hat. Deswegen ist es auch kein Zufall, dass bei Elversberg auf den Trikots Hülow ist. Also Hülow Eyecare, das ist eine Marke von Ursa Farm. Und da wird auch darüber, dass über diesen Investor wird auch das Stadion finanziert. Also es ist reiner Privatbau. Da ist jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig was mit städtisch oder so, sondern es ist reiner Privatbau. Und auch der Verein wird und wurde damit mitfinanziert. Also das ist jetzt nicht einfach so vom Himmel gefallen, dass man da auf einmal jetzt einen Zweitliga-Standort hat, sondern das ist ein Investor hinten dran und der gibt natürlich Geld. Wenngleich die Dimension natürlich im Vergleich zu anderen Investoren schon noch geringer ist. Aber das ist jetzt auch mit, dass da Unmengen in Geld verbrannt wird oder da so lange reingepumpt wird, bis irgendwas funktioniert. Aber da muss man schon sagen, man lebt jetzt nicht mit dem Horror-Szenario, dass man sich da irgendwie total verschuldet oder so.
Mit wie vielen Prozent ist da drin?
Also da Elversberg ist noch ein normaler Verein, also das muss man, kann man auch dazu sagen. Also Frank Holzer an sich ist nur noch der Ehrenpräsident, sein Sohn, der ist mittlerweile der Präsident des Vereins. Aber ansonsten, also wie gesagt, Elversberg hat sich über die letzten Jahre schon einen großen Sponsorenstamm auch aufgebaut. Das wurde über die letzten Jahre immer mehr. Und das merkt man auch, dass man da diese Last auf mehrere Schultern verteilen will. Aber ich sage mal, wenn Frank Holzer jetzt sagen wird, ich ziehe mich hier zurück und lasse da jetzt keinen Euro mehr, dann wird es schwierig. Also das ist schon eine gewisse Abhängigkeit, die da ist. Das auf jeden Fall.
Aber also 50 plus 1 sonst in dem Sinne schon faktisch gegeben.
Faktisch gegeben, theoretisch ist halt der Sohn Präsident des Vereins.
Also der Martin Kind von Elversberg.
Ja, das sind keine Hörgeräte.
Ja, you get the point. Ja, ist natürlich schon immer auch wichtig, das nicht so ganz außen vor zu lassen, dass man ja doch dann noch mit einer anderen Ruhe durchaus arbeiten kann. Also muss man ja einfach sagen, das ist was anderes. Wenn da so eine gewisse finanzielle Sicherheit dahinter steht, da gehst du vielleicht nicht. Da weiß man dann auch, ein Abstieg in die 3. Liga bedeutet dann nicht sofort, ja, okay, wir müssen jetzt innerhalb von einem Jahr wieder aufsteigen, sonst, oder Minimum zwei Jahre, weil sonst sieht es mal uns finanziell mal ganz dunkel aus. Liebe Grüße an Duisburg und Co. So, das ist ja einfach so. Also das ist ja eine andere Voraussetzung.
Das ist auch, wenn man das so ein bisschen mit dem anderen großen Verein im Saarland, also mit Saarbrücken, vergleicht. Saarbrücken hat auch mit Hartmut Osnermann, jemanden, der über Jahre hinweg in diesen Verein Geld reingesteckt hat, der auch Präsident dieses Vereins ist, der auch als Saarbrücken bei Saarbrücken richtig schlecht aussah, da richtig Geld reingesteckt hat, nur halt die haben das Problem, dass die halt mit diesem Stadion, mit dem Ludwigspark, der ist halt städtisch so. Und das ist halt für die ein echtes Problem, ob das Umbau ist oder sonst was oder ob das der Rasen ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hoffe euer Rasen ist stabil.
Aber das ist halt für die ein echtes Problem. Und diese Problematiken, sich mit der Stadt auseinanderzusetzen, die hast du halt in Elversberg nicht. Das machts, arbeiten halt schon ruhiger.
Ja. Gut, ich abmoderiere den Teil mal gerade. Das war nicht gutes Deutsch, aber egal. Die nächsten Spiele bzw. die drei Spiele vor der Winterpause sind Nürnberg zu Hause, Braunschweig auswärts und Schalke zu Hause. Wir haben jetzt die Tabelle auch genug besprochen, um sich ungefähr vorstellen zu können, was das bedeutet. Man ist von allen dreien Vereinen zu wissen, dass der, der am höchsten postiert ist. Das sind ja auf jeden Fall schon mal Good News. Nicht so Good News gibt es währenddessen bei Regensburg. Entschuldigung für diese grauenhafte Überleitung. Man ist auf Platz 18, 8 Punkte, 5 zu 33 Tore. Es tut mir leid, ich habe gesagt, ich muss es sagen. Zwei Siege, zwei Unbeschiebungen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin taub.
10 Niederlagen. Es sind momentan 4 Punkte Abstand auf Münster, auf Rang 17 und Ulm, die haben eben auch 12 Punkte. Die sind ein Rang drüber. Es gab jetzt am Wochenende nur 0-0 gegen Braunschweig, wo ich...
Ja, herrlich.
Ja, ich hatte großen Spaß, mir diese Spiele anzugucken.
Ja, ich auch, ich habe es kommentiert.
Ai, ai, ai, mein Beileid an der Stelle. Obwohl man ja sagen muss, also wenn man sagt, es gab ein besseres Team, muss man ja schon sagen, es waren am Ende die Regensburger. Also für mich waren sie auf jeden Fall die mit den mehr Torchancen, dass man bei fünf Toren, fünf bisher erzielten Toren vielleicht nicht so die ganz große, das ganz große Selbstbewusstsein vorne drin hat und dann vielleicht auch sagt so, hey, lass mal nicht das ganz große Risiko hinten rausgehen, weil, wenn ich richtig nachgezählt habe, ist zumindest in der Liga das erste vierte Spiel ohne Gegentor gewesen. Man hat ja tatsächlich ironischerweise im DFB-Pokal zweimal zu Null gespielt, 1-0 gegen Bochum und 1-0 gegen die Spielvereinigung führt.
Ich sagte schon Arnold Schwarzenegger, you have to shock the buzzer. Immer mit Überraschungsmoment arbeiten. Es ist funktioniert.
Und es gab natürlich, das darf man nicht außen vor lassen, auch einen Trainerwechsel. Und Joe Enochs musste nach dem 8-3 gegen Nürnberg gehen.
Das habe ich auch kommentiert.
Das ist eine Verbesserung, Kindchen. Wollen wir mal hier noch ein bisschen tiefer sehen. Und jetzt ist eben Andreas Patz. Ich glaube, er war als Interimstrainer eingeplant. Und dann hat man eben gesagt, man geht mit ihm weiter. Zumindest bis zur Winterpause.
Oder auf jeden Fall.
Bis zum Ende der Saison, richtig. Ich habe das mit Vierfahrer gezeigt.
Und jetzt hat er einen neuen Co-Trainer dafür geholt, von Jena. Keine Ahnung, war da U19-Trainer. Die Jena-Fans wünschen ihm alles Gute. Von den Ergebnissen kann man nichts sagen. Die U19 von Jena ist, glaube ich, nicht so nötig gut momentan. Irgendwoher muss man die Leute kennen. Das war ja bei Joe Enochs auch nicht anders. Der kannte Andreas Patz auch. Und so kamen die da dazu. Das ist halt immer so ein bisschen eine Spätselwitschaft.
Genau. Unter Patz ja ein Sieg, zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden, nur eins zu drei Tore. Das ist zumindestens ein... Also man kassiert jetzt nicht mehr so viele. Davor war es ja auch mal schön der Schnitt, der Dreier Schnitt an Gegentoren pro Spiel. Lass uns doch generell erst mal über das Schönere sprechen bei Regensburg. Weil...
Über was?
Über den Aufstieg. Es gibt ja kein...
Willst du da mit mir drüber sprechen? Ich erinnere mich an eine Rasenfunk-Ausgabe letztes Jahr. Da habe ich eine sehr verdutzte und nicht ganz glückliche Eva Blotter-Bohle gehört über unseren Aufstieg. Da war ich auch etwas krantig. Da habe ich überlegt, ob ich etwas sagen soll.
Alles kommt zurück im Leben.
Na ja.
Sprich, meine Liebste, sprich.
Es kostet mich gerade eine Stimme. Sie verweigert einfach die Aufstieg.
Ich fange einfach mal kurz an. Ich meine, unser Aufstieg war am Ende, also grundsätzlich überraschend, unabhängig von der Saison und vom Saisonverlauf. Weil, ich meine, den wenigsten Absteigern gelingt ja mittlerweile der direkte Wiederaufstieg, vor allem mit diesem riesigen Adalast, den wir hatten. Wir haben dann die Mannschaft verpflichtet, und ich sage mal so, damals, als das war, war man schon glücklich, weil man einfach das Gefühl hatte, die haben wieder Bock. Also wie gesagt, wir haben über Leihspieler gesprochen, auch über einen, den du auch kennst. Und als Mirza in den Begutsch gegangen ist und alles, da war ja alles, da war keine gute Stimmung, da war eben das, wenn sich die vielleicht auch zu wichtig nehmen, etc., PP, keine gute Team-Chemie. Dann hatten wir diese brutale Hinrunde. Ich meine, man darf natürlich nicht vergessen, dass die Spieler, die wir haben, doch irgendwo auch schon einen Namen hatten. Ich meine, Robin Ziegler ist kein Unbekannter, Nidia Soud war kein Unbekannter, Flo Balas ist kein Unbekannter, ich zähle jetzt nicht alle einzeln auf, aber mit denen konnte man schon was anfangen. Und ich meine, Joe Enochs ist ja per se kein schlechter Trainer, menschlich. Absolut top. Also wir als Block haben ihm sehr viel zu verdanken, weil er uns einfach dadurch geholfen hat. Und es ist unglaublich schade, dass er nicht mehr da ist, aber das war halt jetzt am Ende einfach alternativlos und auch seit der Rückrunde wahrscheinlich schon alternativlos. Das ist jetzt wieder die Frage, da scheiden sich jetzt wieder die Geister. Diejenigen, die immer höher, immer weiter heutzutage wollen, die haben gesagt, wir hätten jetzt ein letztes Jahr schon entlassen müssen. Die, wo natürlich jetzt eher wie ich so treu da wahrscheinlich, nennt man das, die sagen, hä, komm, was soll denn das? Aber jetzt am Ende ging es halt einfach nicht mehr, weil halt einfach, ich meine, so ganz sinnbildlich beim Spiel gegen Nürnberg hat irgendwann Alexander Bittroff von der Seite mitgekocht. Weil ENOX es nicht geschafft hat, die Spieler irgendwie zu beruhigen. Man glaubt, ich glaube nicht, dass es gegen ENOX war, aber irgendwas hat halt einfach nicht gepasst. Man darf natürlich aber auch nicht vergessen, nach dem Aufstieg, der ja schon sehr glücklich war, und das ganze Glück, was uns vielleicht in der 2. Liga-Saison als wir abgestiegen sind gefehlt hat, das haben wir natürlich alles in der 3. Liga anscheinend aufgebracht. Und jetzt sind wir ein bisschen in der Realität, und da darf es nicht sagen, unser Kader hat sich in der 4. Liga-Verhältnisse gut gelesen, aber in der 2. Liga ist es heute wahrscheinlich einfach in vielen Punkten zu wenig. Um jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz bei Alex Bittroff zu bleiben, er hat einen super guten Zweikampfwert, was ich weiß, aber du kannst ihn ja nicht in kein Lauftuer mehr schicken. Das kannst du vergessen. Und wir haben auch viele Spieler, denen wahrscheinlich ein Jahr in der 3. Liga noch gut getan hätte, die diese Zeit gebraucht hätten. Wenn man sich Noah Garnas anschaut in der Regionalliga, der Regionalliga, der 3. Liga, jetzt ist er in der 2. Liga. Das ist natürlich viel schwer. Und natürlich macht an einem gewissen Punkt auch der Kopf nicht mehr so mit. Und in der Phase ist unsere Mannschaft so ein bisschen.
Ja, du hast jetzt auch sehr schnell die positiven Parts abgehandelt. Also ich meine, ich erinnere mich, dass dein Kollege Max, der hat uns damals nach dem Ausstieg eine Sprachnachricht für Freunde geschickt und hatte ungefähr ähnlich viele Stimme wie ich. Ja, ich weiß. Er hatte doch schon viel Euphorie. Aber ich glaube, es ist auch einfach schwierig, wenn man mit Ulm und Münster zwei Mitaufsteiger hat, die ja wirklich diesen Durchmarsch gemacht haben. Und vielleicht glaube ich einfach von außen diesen Tick weniger zu verlieren haben. Weil eben Regensburg, dieser Wiederaufsteiger, war einfach nur von außen. Also dass Regensburg trotzdem kein klassischer– nicht als Beleidigung ansehen– klassischer Zweitligist in dem Sinne war, wie man ihn vielleicht sonst sieht. Dass sie diesen Euphorie-Part natürlich ganz anders nochmal mitnehmen. Also wenn du halt von der Regionalliga in die 3. Liga und dann in die 2. Liga aufsteigst, ist ja schon was anderes.
Das sagt man ja auch.
Ja, ja, aber bei euch war ja schon noch 2. Liga, 3. Liga, 2. Liga. Also davor kam ja der Abstieg. Das ist ja schon nochmal…
Na, damals als wir aufgestiegen sind. Wir sind ja von der 3. runter und dann wieder durchhoch. Ich weiß aber, was du meinst. Ich denke, das große Thema, was einfach momentan schwierig ist und was es auch schwierig macht, ist halt, du brauchst eine Ruhe im Umfeld, meiner Meinung nach. Und ich meine, ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, was in der Mannschaft ist, was im Funktionsgebäude passiert, weil logischerweise bin ich da nicht. Ich kann ja nur von dem reden, was dich in den Fankreisen so umtreibt. Und ich denke, dass es halt einfach meiner Meinung nach heutzutage ein bisschen diese Portion Realismus einfach ist, die überall abhanden kommt. Und weil du so gesagt hast, dieser klassische Zweitblick ist ein sehr liebes Thema, das mir oft auffällt und das mir unglaublich auf die Nerven geht, ist zum Beispiel, wenn es wieder heißt, bei Regensburg ist keinem Stadion. Ja, nur wenn halt niemand hinschaut und sieht, dass halt unsere Kameras auf die VIP-Tribüne gerichtet sind und herum herum alles voll ist. Aber das sind halt auch die selben Menschen, die, wenn du fragst, hey, willst du eine Traditions-Bundesliga, die 60 sagen? 60 zwar nicht mal wissen, wo es liegt, obwohl man eigentlich weiß, dass es in München ist, so nach dem Motto. Was willst du denn dann von solchen Menschen erwarten? Und das ist halt einfach– aber auch bei den Jahn-Fans heutzutage mittlerweile diese Sache– du musst dir einfach mal klar sein, dass du halt einfach nicht diese Ansprüche haben kannst, in der 2. Liga jetzt schon so richtig etabliert zu sein. Ja, wir waren etabliert der 2. Liga, und wir sind weit weg von der Gefahr, glaube ich, komplett durchgereicht zu werden in Oberliga, Regionalliga, was auch immer. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich meine, unser Finanzvorstand sagt es immer wieder, wir sind in der 2. Liga unterm Duschen, und da sind wir schlusslich. Ich meine, wenn man überlegt, als ich Jahn-Fan geworden bin vor 10 Jahren, haben die noch in einem alten Jahn-Stall gespielt, wo sich Borussia Mönchengladbach geweigert hat, darin zu duschen, wo es geschimmelt hat. Also, was erwartet man dann? Das sagt man wieder, ja, es sind 10 Jahre her. Ja, jeder, der sich mit Geldmarkt und Co. beschäftigt, weiß, was 10 Jahre sind. Nix. Und da bist du halt. Und dieses Geld kannst du nicht so einfach aufholen und diese ganzen Infrastrukturen, weil Jonas gesagt hat, von wegen 2. Mannschaft, NLZ, wir suchen momentan auch nach dem Nachwuchsleistungszentrum oder möchten eins bauen. Jetzt weiß ja jeder, der sich ein bisschen mit der allgemeinen Lage hier in Deutschland beschäftigt, wie teure Immobilien sind. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei euch oben so ist, aber Bayern ist teuer. Regensburg ist recht. Jetzt baust du das Aushalt von Regensburg. Da ist es natürlich die 2. Liga und der Pokal der Gölzigen. Ohne das wird es viel länger dauern. Das musst du halt alles aufholen. Und um zu meiner Ursprungs-Sache zurückzukommen, da muss man halt einfach mal so realistisch sein. Wir können es in der 2. Liga schaffen, ja. Aber ich habe damals, als wir aufgeschrieben sind, für mich selber gedacht, also mehr wie Platz 15 wird es auf gar keinen Fall. Und auch das mit vielen Hängeln und Würgen und Strecken. Weil wir haben kaum Abgänge gehabt. Wir haben schon ein paar gute Zugänge, aber diese Zugänge kommen ja nicht ohne Grund zum Jahn. Ich meine, wenn wir da so eine Wahl hätten, dann hätten wir uns auch einen Tom Zimmercheat geholt. Aber der ist ja nicht ohne Grund lieber zu Elversberg als zu uns.
Aber der wird ja bei euch eh nicht treffen.
Abgesehen davon, aber so, naja, das ist halt, also für mich ist eines der großen Probleme heutzutage, diese Definition von Erfolg, weil es heißt immer, derjenige, der das gesagt hat, der weiß das, und ich mag ihn sehr gerne, aber wir sind auf Erfolglosigkeit getrimmt. Ich sehe das Halten eines gewissen Status ist nicht unbedingt als Erfolglosigkeit. Und ich glaube, das ist aber etwas, was momentan im Jahnumfeld viele beschäftigt, weil man halt nicht versteht, warum man sich so präsentiert, und es wirkt, als hätten wir heute aufgegeben. Was halt nicht ist, aber die Realität ist halt einfach, dass du dich halt so schwer tun wirst. Und dass du halt einfach auch wissen musst, woher das kommt, warum das so ist. Das heißt nicht, dass wir uns damit zufrieden geben, auf gar keinen Fall. Also ich bin normalerweise vor jedem Spiel von mir an gut gelaunt, weil ich denke, komm, heute geht was, heute geht wieder nichts. Aber teilweise waren die Auftritte sehr ernüchternd. Also um das nur mal kurz zu sagen, gegen Braunschweig war ich schon zufrieden, weil ich einfach mal wieder ein bisschen einen Kampfgeist gesehen habe. Weil ich gesehen habe, sie spielen, sie können kombinieren, sie können mal einen Ball halten, ich kann sie immer noch nicht schlagen, Jonas, ich bin bei dir. Aber jetzt wie zum Beispiel gegen Nürnberg, da stehst du einfach irgendwann im Stadion, du schreist dir die Seele aus dem Leib, weil du es nicht verstehst. Weil du verstehst es einfach nicht. Manche Gegend, also wir haben es nach dem Spiel in Braunschweig gesagt, zum Leben zu wenig, zum Sterben zu viel, aber so stirbst du halt trotzdem. Und auch jetzt, ich bin nach wie vor überzeugt, wir können die Klasse halten. Aber alles über Platz 15 ist für mich ein Wunder. Also sag ich dir, wie es ist.
Ist ja am Ende trotzdem, also auf der Grundlage, dann einen neuen Kader vielleicht irgendwie doch zusammenstellen, ist natürlich trotzdem gut. Ich fand es halt so krass, ich habe Regensburg gegen die Hertha live im Stadion gesehen. Bitte in der Frage nicht meine Wahl der Fußballspiele, die ich mir am Wochenende angucke live im Stadion.
Das ist gut.
Also ich fand das so krass, weil ich schon irgendwie fand, dass Regensburg da auch lange Zeit echt gut dagegen gehalten hat. Und dann musste man irgendwann hinten aufmachen und das war irgendwie so, wo man schon sehen konnte, warum bekommt man denn so viele Gegentore? Weil man immer das Gefühl hatte, sobald das Erste fällt, bricht da vielleicht auch so ein bisschen was raus. Und das ist ja auch irgendwann Kopfsache. Es ist ja einfach so, diesen Part kann man nicht rausnehmen. Also, warum hat man dann gleichzeitig erst nur fünf Tore, auch nur fünf unterschiedliche Torschützen in der Liga? Das kommt ja auch noch dazu. Also, man kann das ja immer von zwei Seiten sehen. Entweder man sagt, es kommen mehrere Spieler in die Position, ein Tor zu schießen. Oder man sagt halt, es fehlt halt momentan der Spieler, der, wo man weiß, hey, Flanke und Tor. Einfach Schema A, rein mit dem Ball. Mit Kai Pröger hat man ja zumindest einen durchaus erfahrenen Spieler. Aber auch der ist ja ehrlich gesagt von seiner Prime-Zeit weg.
Wir haben seit Jahren ein Problem in der Offensive. Nicht nur erst seit diesem Jahr. Als wir noch Andreas Albers hatten, hatten wir zwar Tore, aber jetzt nicht diese Weltantoren. Da sind wir aber wieder bei dem Punkt. Für manche Spieler ist vielleicht die 2. Liga entweder das Limit oder sie sind halt noch nicht so weit. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja ein paar gute Stimmen. Also in Noah Garners hat er Anlagen. Eine Leosuth ist schon irgendwo eine verlässliche Bank. Auch wenn man mit der Autorin mich jetzt auf den Kopf abschlägt. Wer aus der Orotak-Bo hat gute Ansätze in Kai Pröger, gute Ansätze in Christian Kühfeldt, der ist unglaublich erfahren. Aber jetzt beim Spieler wieder gegen Braunschweig, du hast halt einfach immer noch, es gibt immer noch das gute Pech. Das gibt es halt einfach auch noch. Und dann aus welchem Grund auch immer sehr falsche Entscheidungen getroffen. Der Kopf ist vielleicht nicht ganz da. Es ist vielleicht am Ende Qualitätsfrage. Und dann muss halt die Mannschaft schauen, dass sie das auf die Straße bringt. Also ich will da nicht einzelne Spieler rauspicken. Die Kritik sind, das steht mir nicht zu, weil ich auch selber nie Fußball gespielt habe. Und B, ich mich natürlich als Zuschauer leichter redet. Sondern, ja, steht mal rüber, dann passt das schon. Aber es ist einfach Fakt, dass wir unglaubliche Probleme in der Offensive haben. Das haben wir seit Jahren. Deshalb haben wir natürlich diesmal noch Probleme in der Verteidigung dazu bekommen. Auf den Außenverteidigern ganz speziell. Da hat man ja auch schon mal das Thema. Das kann man sicherlich unserem Sportverstand angreifen. Da kommen wir wahrscheinlich auch noch dazu. Aber ja, um auf das nochmal zu kommen, du hast es ja so schön gesagt, ich habe das positive versucht vorzugeben, aber mir ist schon durchaus klar, dass wir sehr viel Negatives haben. Bei fünf Torschützen wäre gut, wenn wir 15 Tore hätten und nicht fünf.
Ja.
Und vor allem nicht bei 33 Gegentoren. Bei 33 Gegentoren möchte ich nur eine Sache sagen, und das ist auch etwas, was beim Trainerwechsel schon klar geworden ist. Er hat es geschafft, das mehr zu stabilisieren. Nichtsdestotrotz haben wir immer noch Fehler drin. Wir haben natürlich Glück, dass einer unserer Jugendspieler brutal durch die Decke geht. Also Pauli Wurm hätte ich fast ein Denkmal gebaut, wenn er so nur ein Tor geschossen hätte. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das halt so ein… Du musst sagen, du hast beim Jahr nicht ein großes Problem, du hast überall so Probleme. Du musst halt versuchen, eins nach dem anderen anzugehen. Und das ist halt für einen Fan, glaube ich, sehr schwer zu ertragen. Weil du willst natürlich gern sehen, dass die Abwehr steht, dass wir geile Flanken schlagen und am besten nur drei Wuden. Aber das geht nicht.
Ja, und es ist natürlich… Also es ergibt natürlich auch total Sinn, dass man jetzt erstmal Minimum bis zur Winterpause sagt, wir stabilisieren erstmal die Abwehr und dann gucken wir weiter. Weil man hat einfach diesen Kredit mit diesen 33 Gegendoren. Die kriegst du ja nicht durch, wenn du fünf Spiele mal keins kriegst, dann werden die ja nie weniger. Sondern das ist natürlich einfach gleichbleibend. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber so, du kannst ja nicht beides… Also meistens kannst du gerade, wenn du in dieser Position bist, du kannst nicht beides gleichzeitig machen. Du kannst nicht sagen, wir stabilisieren jetzt die Defensive und wir gucken jetzt, dass unsere Offensive pro Spiel doch drei Tore mehr schießt als der Gegner. So ungefähr.
Du musst…
Funktioniert nicht. Alles gut. Und das, ich meine, man muss dann auch sagen, es sind jetzt auch drei Spiele bis zur Winterpause. So und dann ist aber, glaube ich, auch da wieder super wichtig, was passiert denn in der Winterpause? Hat man überhaupt irgendwie die finanziellen Möglichkeiten? Aber ehrlich gesagt doch einfach sowieso, wie agiert man auf dem Transfermarkt? Und du hast es schon angesprochen, wie sieht da denn die Situation gerade aus, sowohl finanziell als auch vom Sporvorstand her?
Finanziell will ich nicht sagen, aber deutscher Meister wird nur der Jan. Wir sind eins hinter Bayern. Also ich meine, das ist auch, wenn ihr mal einen Köln-Fan zu Gast habt, die Arbeit auch von Christian Köhler mit gewesen und seinem damaligen Prokuristen Philipp Hausner, die wahnsinnige Arbeit geleistet haben. Wir sind unglaublich gesund. Wir haben positives Eigenkapital. Aber um da mal einen schönen Vergleich heranzuziehen, wie sollst du die Dinge, also bei, wenn ich jetzt sage, Hansa Rostock, dass die nicht viel Geld haben, obwohl sie die Nummer 1 in ihrem Bundesland sind, wenn man dann sagt, McPom mit ihrer Struktur oben, ist ja nicht so verwunderlich. So und jetzt bist du bei uns in Bayern, wo du ewig viel Konkurrenz hast. Also und die Oberpfalz ist halt schon jetzt nicht strukturschwach, aber woher soll das ganze Geld kommen? Und ich meine, für welchen Sponsor, Investor, WM, ich meine, wir haben nicht ohne Grund Netto. Netto ist originalerweise aus Regensburg. Und also von den Finanzen, das würde schon gut ausschauen, aber in der heutigen Zeit vom Profifußball, wo alles unbundlich viel Geld kostet, kannst du das schon kaufen, dann gefährdest du halt wieder alles. Dann bist du eben mit einem Ding, wo du sagst, wir können jetzt schon für Millionen Spieler kaufen, dann muss halt unser NLZ länger warten. Jetzt was ist denn wichtiger für einen Jahn? Einen guten Spieler zu kaufen, ein NLZ. Wo willst du auf lange Sicht hin? Welche Vision hast du nicht? Ich denke, als Jahn Regensburg muss man sich da schon klar sein, dass wir die Nummer 5, 6 in Bayern wahrscheinlich sind und dass wir da gar nicht die Ansprüche haben sollten, fertige Spieler zu kaufen oder auch einen fertigen Trainer. Ich meine, natürlich gäbe es mega interessante Trainerkandidaten, sei es Steffen Baumgart, Zorniger und Co., aber ich denke, Steffen Baumgart verdient so viel, wie uns der Sponsor im Jahr zahlt. Also wie sollen wir sowas holen? Und darum musst du halt schauen, was du machst. Und ich denke, mit einer Laie werden wir gut beraten. Vielleicht findet sich aber auch eine günstige, gute Alternative. Zum Transfermarkt genommen an sich, das ist eine große Kritik an unserem neuen Sportchef und auch in Bayerlötze, dass er nicht gut geplant hat. Ich meine, wir haben verletzungsanfällige Spieler, Robin Siegele, Oskar Schönfelder und solche Sachen. Und jetzt fällt Oskar Schönfelder nach einem bösen Fall wieder weg. War das nicht sogar gegen Elversberg? Nein, das war früher. Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht mehr. Der sich wieder am Knie schwer verletzt hat. Und jetzt hast du nur noch Brian Hain. Ich will nicht auf Brian Hain drauf fahren, weil er sich stark gesteigert hat. Er hat das immer besser angenommen, er hat das gut adaptiert. Aber nichtsdestotrotz hast du jetzt nur noch Brian Hain. Was ist, wenn mit dem was ist? Oder wenn er mal in eine Formkrise wiederkommt. Dann eben in der Offensive haben viele Leute geholt. Christian Kühlwetter, der keine Spielpraxis hatte ewig, der zwar schon zeigt, dass er es kann, aber irgendwo platzt der Knoten nicht. Und man merkt halt einfach, dass irgendwo man sagt das immer so mit einem lachenden Auge, das Telefonbuch von Achim Beierlotz anscheinend ziemlich leer ist, weil er anscheinend niemanden kennt, wo wir uns was leihen können. Dass man mal bei Beiern fragt, habt ihr wen, den ihr uns leihen könntet, so nach dem Motto. Das redet sich aber halt immer alles so leicht. Das ist das Problem, wo ich mit viele dieser Kritik an den ganzen Sachen habe, weil Vivo spielen kann ich auch. Das war halt leider nicht das echte Leben. Also wir haben Bedarf, wir brauchen einen Außenverteidiger, definitiv, eventuell noch mal einen Sturm. Aber ich denke, wir müssen damit leihen arbeiten und schauen, was wir bekommen. Und nochmal, der Jahn hat schon ein bisschen Geld, aber ich denke nicht, dass der Jahn in der Position ist, sich fertige, ich nenne es jetzt mal Produkte, Entschuldigung für den Ausdruck, Produkte zu kaufen. Wir können jetzt nicht losziehen und sagen, hey, wir holen uns jetzt ein, wie hat euer Außenverteidiger geheißen Baum, Baum, Braun?
Baum ist geliehen von Freiburg, von Frankfurt, Entschuldigung.
Als blöds Beispiel, wir können jetzt nicht hergehen und sagen, hey, Frankfurt, beenden wir mal die Laie mit Elversberg, wir kaufen uns jetzt einen Baum. In der Lage sind wir nicht. Wir könnten aber fragen, hey, Frankfurt, habt ihr vielleicht noch einen Verteidiger, den ihr uns leihen könntet, der aber halt dann Zeit braucht, sich zu entwickeln. Und ich denke, das ist halt auch die Idee hinter Andi Patz. Also tun wir nichts weg, es wird sehr kritisch gesehen, weil er hat natürlich unter Enok schon gearbeitet, also was soll sich großartig ändern. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es eben das, was viele immer fordern, eine interessante Alternative. Klar wäre es vielleicht schöner gewesen, wenn du eine andere interessante Alternative gehabt hättest und Andi noch mal ins zweite Klick getreten wäre, um zu lernen und vielleicht damals zu übernehmen. Aber du musst halt schauen, was du kriegst, was sich entwickelt. Und das ist, also wie gesagt Außenverteidiger, eventuell findest du in der Offensive welche, wo du eher abgeben kannst oder verleihen kannst, dass sie sich vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt machen können. Ansonsten eine große Kritik von mir, die ich schon damals hatte, ist Rebuild 2025. Heutzutage gibt es ja anscheinend nur noch 2-Jahres-Verträge. Das ist jetzt anscheinend meine FIFA-Welt gewesen persönlich, weil ich hätte immer längere Verträge gemacht. Bei uns laufen 2025 wieder alle Verträge aus. Also wenn wir auch absteigen, ich glaube dann gehen wieder 10 Leute. Und da musst du halt auch schauen, wen willst du vielleicht behalten, wen willst du nicht behalten. Also das ist halt auch ein schwieriges Thema. Und wie gesagt, dann der Stürrhoch dann auch in Bayer-Lorz in seiner ersten Sportdirektor-Position. Der halt auch lernen muss. Und da bist du halt jetzt die Frage, willst du ihm die Zeit geben und lernen lassen? Wo jetzt ich persönlich schon ein Fan davon bin, aber ich kann auch viele kritische Stimmen verstehen. Ich sage, Fußball ist Ergebnis-Sport, Fußball ist Erfolg, es muss erfolgreich sein und die Zeit gibt man ihm nicht. Na dann muss man halt auch wieder sagen, dann haben wir den vierten Sportdirektor innerhalb seit zwei Jahren, seitdem Christian Köhler weg ist.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, da muss man sich schon entscheiden mit NLZ oder wenn man auf Teufel kommt raus vielleicht die Klasse halten. Und jetzt, also zehn Spieler wären vielleicht weg, wenn man absteigt. Wie groß wäre denn die Katastrophe, wenn man jetzt absteigen würde? Also was würden denn das für Regensburg und für den Verein bedeuten?
Das ist eben das, wo ich gesagt habe, dass wir in so einer guten Lage sind. Wir würden nicht untergehen. Wir würden jetzt nicht in Fahrwasser gekommen. Da muss mich Eva bitte korrigieren, wenn ich sage, wie es bei Bielefeld anscheinend damals war, als es so schlimm ausgeschaut hat. Oder bei Duisburg oder mit 60 oder so. Das auf gar keinen Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall. Natürlich profitieren wir davon ein bisschen vom städtischen Stadion, das im Schwarzbuch der bunte Steuerzahler war. Und der FDP-Stadtrat regt sich immer noch auf.
Kann ja mal eine Pyramide basteln.
Nein, aber wir würden es überleben. Eventuell müssten wir wieder Einsprachungen machen. Also vielleicht, dass das eine Videoanalyse, der Oli Seitz für euch vielleicht wieder gehen müsste, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Aber wir würden definitiv klar kommen. Wir dürfen natürlich auch nicht zu lange bleiben, weil das natürlich den Bau des NHZs immer weiter nach hinten schiebt. Darum ist ja der DFB-Pokal für uns so ein Segen. Um einmal die Finanzen von Regensburg ganz einfach darzustellen, nehmen wir uns unseren Jugend-Spieler, den Pauli Wurm, weil er so gute Leistungen bringt. Dann sagt Elversberg, den will ich. Dann sagt er, wir bieten euch eine Million. Dann sagt der Jan, nimm Pauli Wurm, unser NHZ ist bezahlt. Passt. So sind unsere Finanzen. Das hört sich jetzt an, als wären wir die ärmsten Kirchenmäuse. Das nicht. Aber dann hätten wir heute unser Ziel so erreicht. Wir könnten das finanzieren und hätten vielleicht nur was übrig. So. Einfach sehr konservativ wahrscheinlich.
Eine Million bis NHZ-Finanzierung ist jetzt auch nicht so viel. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel hier in Bielefeld, da sollte es auch wahnsinnig lange neues NHZ geben. Und im Endeffekt hat man es eben mit der Hilfe von Goldberg hier geschafft. Also einem lokalen Unternehmer, der hat halt das NHZ jetzt gebaut. Und ich meine, wenn man es vergleicht, Bielefeld hat zwischenzeitlich zwei Jahre Bundesliga gespielt, lange vorher, oder zweite Liga. Also es ist eben, um einfach zu unterstreichen, eben gerade in der NHL, also in Bielefeld gibt es immer noch keine U23-Mannschaft, weil es einfach extrem teuer ist, sowas auf Dauer zu finanzieren. Und das sind natürlich so verschiedene Dinge, die einander dann auch bedingen. Also wenn bei dir immer ab der U19 Schluss ist, um auch eben jüngere Spieler auszubilden oder irgendwie das für dich attraktiv zu machen, dann ist natürlich auch etwas schwierig. Und ich glaube dahingehend, dass das schon, ja, ist ein schwieriger Weg. Aber ja, also ich wüsste es jetzt auch nicht. Also ich glaube, ich bin generell einfach kein großer Arjen-Bayer-Lorz-Affent. Ich weiß nicht, war ich nie. Aber ja, klar, also ich meine, man muss ja auch sagen, wahrscheinlich eine Finanz-, also beziehungsweise Präsidium, ich weiß nicht genau, wie es bei euch strukturiert ist. Aber wer immer auch gesagt hat, hier, Bayer-Lorz, er soll den Job machen. Ich meine, also wenn ich jemanden einstelle, wo ich weiß, er hat noch keine Erfahrung, dann muss ich natürlich aber auch überlegen, was mache ich denn jetzt? Also dass das jetzt keine einfachen Jahre werden auch oder Monate auch, muss einem dann ja auch bewusst sein. Also da ist ja dann immer die Frage, welchen Weg wollten wir auch mit Bayer-Lorz gehen?
Hast du dich mit Max vorher unterhalten?
Nein.
Sicher? Weil Max ist auch ein großer Kritiker unseres Präsidenten. Zu Recht, weil ich meine, das Präsidium muss sich ja vorwerfen lassen, hey, ihr habt vor Bayer-Lorz zwei nicht erfolgreiche Sportdirektoren gehabt und jetzt wieder eventuell ein nicht erfolgreiches. Was ist da los? Ich meine, beim Jahn ist es übrigens, ich glaube, das ist auch ganz interessant, weil ich gerade nochmal nachschau, auf den Pfarreien gehören 90 Prozent vom Jahn, 10 Prozent sind der Rest, wobei ich da eine witzige Anekdote noch einstreuen kann. In Regensburg gab es ja die Spendenaffäre, wer das mal will, kann das mal nachlesen. Und dieser Bauträger, der die Teile gehabt hat, hat das an einen Investor verkauft und dieser Investor, der hat mich meine damalige Vollgesetze in meiner Arbeit angesprochen, die hatte ein Haus, wollte das verkaufen, der wollte das kaufen. Der wirkt aber nicht sehr seriös, ich habe gesagt, ja, lassen sie es bleiben, das ist beim Jahn auch nicht sehr seriös. Wenn man die Fans protestiert, dann muss der das wieder zurückverkaufen. Also so ist das alles ein bisschen zustande gekommen. Meines Präsidiums muss ich natürlich auch Fragen gefallen lassen. Ich denke, was beim Jahn jetzt wieder so, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll, das ist jetzt vielleicht sehr einfacher, das mit sehr vielen Klischees gesagt, aber ich meine, wir sind heute hier in der Oberpfalz. Regensburg ist schon eine große Stadt, eine bekannte große Stadt, eine schöne große Stadt, aber es ist halt kein Bielefeld, kein Dortmund oder Berlin, wo du halt immer mal wieder irgendwelche Leute hast.
Die Dürraufzählung von Staunen.
Ich soll euch nicht sagen, wir sind halt irgendwo in der Pampa. Wir sind schon, Regensburg ist schon groß, aber da hast du halt drumherum nichts. Ich glaube, der Jonas kann da schon ganz gut mit. Du hast halt im Saarland, da kommt halt erst einmal lange nichts Großes, wo du irgendwo draus ziehen kannst. Das gute Beispiel ist das NSZ, das ist schon wichtig. Das Problem bei unseren Jugendmannschaften, unsere U21 zum Beispiel, ist, die spielen in der Bayernliga. Das heißt, selbst wenn du ein Talent hast, dann musst du in der Bayernliga spielen. Nicht mal in der Regionalliga Bayern, die ja auch nicht gut ist. So im Vergleich zur Regionalliga West-Südwest und solche Sachen. Und ich glaube, da hast du schon so ein bisschen Probleme. Woher kommen halt diese Kontakte? Du merkst halt meiner Meinung nach immer noch, dass der Jan halt einfach klein ist, dass das ganze Umfeld klein ist, dass wir halt auch jahrelang in der Versenkung verschwunden waren, bevor wir damals wieder hochgekommen sind. Das kann dir halt als Miniapide-Feld, die schon Jahrzehnte oben waren, nicht so einfach passieren. Also nicht, sollte man meinen, ne? Und das ist halt etwas, und ich glaube, das ist halt beim Jahr war lange Weg eben auch gescheiterte, in dicken Anführungszeichen-Spieler, also mit einem Karriereknick oder heute junge Regionalliga-Spieler zu verpflichten. Aber man sieht ja, dass das mittlerweile noch mehr machen, wie sonst, und das ist natürlich dann für ein Jahr hart, ich meine, woher willst du da andere ausstechen? Und wie gesagt, das ist, was diesem ganzen, denke ich, diesen Prozess gehört, dass man sich jetzt mal bewusst werden will, wo will man jetzt, also man weiß schon, wo man hin will, man will in diesen Top-Fereien bleiben, man würde gerne auf lange Sicht länger wieder in der 2. Liga bleiben, oder zumindest im oberen Feld vor der 3. Liga erstmal und dann wieder in die 2. Liga und ja, wir sind schon noch vollgesunken, wir wollen wirklich dauerhaft in der 2. Liga bleiben, bloß du musst halt schauen, was du halt aufholen musst, was du für Konkurrenz hast und ja, wie einfach, das ist halt, ich kann es immer nur wieder sagen, das ist nicht so alles, wie man sich das im Fußballmanager vorstellt. Es hört sich blöd an, aber es ist halt so.
Ja. Morgen, Abend oder je nachdem, wenn ihr das hört, vielleicht auch heute Abend schon, geht es dann im DFB-Pokal gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Ist vielleicht einfach mal ein Spiel, wo man, also, sind wir mal ganz realistisch. Pokal hat seine eigenen Gesetze, ich weiß.
Ja, nächstes Jahr heute Europa.
Ja, genau.
Das verstehe ich, frage ich nicht.
Gibt es ja, ist natürlich in den VfB Stuttgart schon nochmal ein anderes Kliber als der VfL Bruchum. Ist einfach so. Aber es, also vielleicht tut es einfach der, also sowohl der Jahn-Säle mal ganz gut, als auch sämtlichen Spielern einfach mal so. Also ich meine, mal gerade eben ins DFB-Pokal, Achtelfinale, kommst halt trotzdem nicht. Und das ist natürlich vielleicht einfach für den Kopf. Ja, eine schöne Sache, wenn du es irgendwie schaffst, zumindest 45 Minuten ganz gut dagegen zu stehen.
Nein, man probiert es. Einfach probieren.
Eben. Und dann geht es jetzt eben am Wochenende gegen Köln, dann ausser jetzt gegen den KSC. Und dann ist das letzte Spiel des Jahres gegen Darmstadt. Auch buntes Potpourri, ehrlich gesagt. Zwei Mal Top 10 dabei. Stand jetzt. Aber, ja, also ich glaube halt wirklich, wir haben, wie gesagt, bei Eintracht Frankfurt, Eintracht Braunschweig, Junge, Junge, Junge, letzte Saison gesehen, dass eben ein, zwei wichtige Entscheidungen im Winter und dann eben gut rauskommen aus dieser Winterpause unfassbar wichtig sein können. Und jetzt eben, es ist eben nochmal eine andere Situation als in der letzten Saison. Und da ist definitiv ja noch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen. Man hat eben den direkten Kontakt und bei einem, eben unter anderem bei einem Schalke 04 und bei einem Führer, da brennt der Baum vielleicht mal ein bisschen früher als…
Wie gesagt, das ist halt, also erstmal mal kurz zum Spiel gegen Stuttgart. Das ist natürlich für viele von der Fanszene, vor allem von der organisierten Fanszene ein tolles Spiel, weil man hat hier eine Fan-Vorschaft mit dem Stuttgarter Kickers. Das ist also, das denke ich, ganz spannend. Ansonsten… Nein, ich überlege gerade, wie ich das sage. Es ist einfach… Ja, es ist schwierig, weil… Vielleicht zeichnet das auch irgendetwas ab einem gewissen Punkt einen Jahn-Fan aus, weil man sich einfach damit abgebunden hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist so, man hat doch gewusst, worauf es hinsteuert. Man hat sich halt mehr erhofft. Und wie gesagt, ich kann es nur noch mal sagen, wenn du noch mehr so Spiele hast wie gegen Nürnberg oder gegen Fürth das erste Mal, oder auch mal wieder so blöde Spiele wie gegen Schalke, wo du halt einfach überhaupt nicht richtig mitgemacht hast, dann brennt bei uns auch der Baum. Also dann ist definitiv wie sowas gegen Braunschweig… Man kann doch darauf aufbauen. Ich meine, viele haben sich schon ein bisschen damit abgefunden, aber es geht halt einfach auch gut darum, sich zu präsentieren. Und ich bin immer noch die Überzeugung, wenn du es halt nochmal schaffst, dich einfach ein bisschen aufzubäumen und diese Probleme nach und nach zu lösen, dann kannst du noch irgendwie dranbleiben. Und das geht halt. Du musst halt dranbleiben. Wenn natürlich jetzt Münster morgen Lauf hat und dann Ullmann läuft, dann haben wir ein Problem. Aber warum sollten die auf einmal so viel mehr in Lauf haben? Die spielen ab und an schöner Fußball, ja. Aber ich bin einfach kein Fan davon, das jetzt halt einfach nur bis zum Saisonende abzuschreiben. Man muss einfach kämpfen, Gas geben. Wie gesagt, wir haben gewusst, worauf es vor der Saison hinausläuft. Und was wären wir für ein Zweitligist, wenn wir es nicht wenigstens versuchen würden, anzunehmen? Aber man muss halt so realistisch bleiben. Wir haben ein Problem, für alle. Wir müssen viel arbeiten. Wir müssen noch viel Lehrgeld zahlen. Es ist auch spannend zu sehen, wie es weitergeht. Und dann muss man auf die nächste Saison blicken. Und ich will es halt nicht abschreiben. So jetzt, wir haben noch, welcher Spieltag war jetzt der? Spieltag, jetzt haben wir einen 15. Spieltag. Wir haben noch eine ganze Rückrunde. Wer weiß, vielleicht holen wir im Winter den Außenverteidiger, der von der Mittellinie dauernd Tor ist. Das tut er nicht wirklich. Ich weiß, dass er nicht.
Bitte, bitte, bitte nicht den Außenverteidiger aus Bielefeld tun und holen, der das wirklich kann.
Wie heißt denn der Name?
Der Luis Abhi, bitte nicht tun.
Nee, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich denke nicht, dass wir höher als 16 kommen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass wir direkt wieder runtergehen. Aber ich weigere mich aufzugeben. Das möchte ich nicht. Ich möchte, dass sie kämpfen. Das war schon immer ein Jahnmarkenzeichen bis zum Ende. Ich möchte auch, dass wir lernen und dass wir nicht einfach nur Kurzschlussreaktionen treffen. Ich glaube, das habe ich auch ein bisschen von Elversberg herausgehört. Da werden auch eine Kurzschlussreaktion getroffen, als wir damals in der Regionalliga rumgetümpelt sind. Da haben wir gesagt, okay, pass auf. So ist der Plan, wie Heidenheim oder Freiburg was gemacht haben. Man hat ja gesehen, dass es bisher funktioniert, wie es funktioniert hatte. Man muss halt was ändern, man muss halt dem Ganzen eine Chance geben und dann wird man sehen.
Das ist halt gerade der Pokal. Der kann ja auch schon vielleicht ein bisschen was freisetzen. Also ich weiß, vor zwei Jahren in der dritten Liga, da haben wir das Pokalspiel gegen Leverkusen gehabt. Das haben wir mit 4 zu 3 gewonnen und das war dann auch wieder so ein, für die dritte Liga. Und ich meine, das war damals eins, wenn nicht sogar das letzte Spiel von St. Joanne in Leverkusen. Das heißt, so gesehen haben wir den Leverkusenern den Meistertitel erst möglich gemacht. Dafür bekamen wir bis jetzt noch nicht mal einen Dankeschön.
Aber naja, und da war ja auch die volle Schuld, dass ich nicht mehr ansehen muss.
Das ist, der Alonso muss noch mal vorbeikommen und sagen, er leidet vielleicht immer ein, zwei Trainings.
Zumindest die Karte wäre doch nett.
Ich denke mir halt einfach am Ende vom Tag immer so, ich sag, klar, man muss irgendwo realistisch bleiben. Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, wie du es schon so gesagt hast, bei Elversberg war es ja genauso, jetzt stell dir mal vor, wir machen im Dezember, aus welchem Grund auch immer, gewinnen wir jetzt gegen Köln und von mir aus gegen Darmstadt, das ist ein blödes Beispiel. Und die anderen beiden spielen so weiter wie bisher. Ja, dann warst du vielleicht schon mal nicht mehr Letzter. Und du weißt ja nicht, was das dann halt ausmacht. Darum, klar, realistisch gesehen gewinnen wir kein einziges. Vielleicht gegen Darmstadt und Unentschieden. Aber ich stelle mir halt einfach vor, wenn ich jetzt Spieler wäre und würde mitbekommen, dass meine Fans grundsätzlich so denken, fände ich das blöd. Und das ist halt einfach nicht meine Einstellung dazu. Und das erwarte ich ja nicht von der Mannschaft. Ich erwarte ja von der Mannschaft, dass sie nicht aufgibt, dass sie kämpft. Da muss ich als Fan, der ich ja am Ende auch nur bin, auch machen. Auch wenn wir, wie gesagt, viele Problemfelder haben und viel zu lösen haben. Und wir werden sehen, wo es hingeht. Wie du auch in Bayer-Lotze geschaut hast, er ist nicht hundertprozentig umstritten. Aus diversen Gründen und seinen diversen Auftritten. Ich denke, er ist immer noch ein Fußballfachmann, aber in gewissen Punkten muss er sich definitiv ändern. Rest wirst du sehen.
Gut, dann würde ich an der Stelle mal sagen, ich habe euch natürlich eine sehr optimistische Zeitangabe für diese Folge gegeben. Ich entschuldige mich, aber es ist auch ein gutes Zeichen, dass wir viel zu bereden hatten. Und von daher will ich es jetzt nach hinten raus. Ich muss es tatsächlich relativ kurz machen. Und euch beiden einfach danken, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Danke Jonas. Schön, dass du uns wieder was zur SVI erzählt hast.
Gar nicht. Komm auch nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ja, und Thomas, ich hoffe, wir hören uns dann nächstes Jahr auch nochmal.
Irgendwas mit Bidefett bestimmt.
Und dann was? Wünsche ich euch schon mal eine schöne Adventszeit noch. Ich glaube, ihr hört mich in diesem Jahr nicht mehr. Schöne Weihnachten an alle, die es feiern. Wir hören uns im neuen Jahr wieder. Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.